[Musique]
houle et des objets qui vous prennent de
votre temps et il en est qui peuvent
vous en donner il est des objets qui
malgré toutes leurs promesses vous vole
littéralement des heures de votre
journée parce que vous êtes sans cesse
obligé de penser à les recharger
les sauvegardes et les mettre à jour
même les mettre à réparer ils nous
sollicitent en permanence
et le pire c'est qu'on répond à leurs
sollicitations et que nos heures passent
et il est des objets qui pourraient
auxquelles on ne prête pas attention
mais qui pourrait vous donner du temps
j'aimerais vous emmener un petit moment
autour de cette question et vous
proposer une façon différente
d'envisager les objets avec lesquels
vous vivez et peut-être de voir les
choses c'est à dire au sens propre voir
les choses
alors cette idée elle est entrée dans ma
vie il ya quelques années lorsque j'ai
visité une exposition qui s'appelait
slow art et qui présentait une dizaine
plusieurs dizaines d'objets qui avaient
tous pour point commun le temps que
leurs créateurs et leurs concepteurs
avaient passé à faire cet objet un temps
souvent très long même la plupart du
temps anormalement longs et qui leur
donnait ce côté fascinant dans leurs
résultats
il y avait par exemple des broderies il
y avait cette robe en tessons de verre
tous accrochés avec des attaches les uns
avec les autres
ce colliers en coquille d'oeuf et parmi
les objets de cette exposition j'ai
rencontré puisqu'on peut parler de
rencontre ce tableau d'une artiste
suédoise qui s'appelle malines lager ce
tableau lorsque je l' ai vu m'a
immédiatement séduit par son côté
mystérieux par son son son côté
fascinant cette ombre comme ça portait
sur le sol et lorsque par contre lorsque
je me suis approché
voici ce que j'ai découvert du tableau
en fait sous la surface ou peut-être
au-dessus il y avait toute cette texture
incroyable cette matière à mon seul et
qui m'a fait réaliser en fait que ce
tableau n'en était pas un ce tableau est
une tapisserie et évidemment quand je
les ai vus quand j'ai réalisé la nature
de la matière
ça m'a plongé dans un abîme de réflexion
sur pourquoi et comment
d'abord pourquoi cet artiste avait elle
choisi une technique aussi chronophage
et comment s'y est elle prise alors je
l'imaginais avec son aiguille en train
de voilà d'entrecroiser tous ses petits
fils de couleurs différentes
alors en réalité malines ne coupa à la
main elle l a détraqué sa machine à
coudre pour rendre son aiguille mobile
et elle utilise donc son aiguille comme
un pinceau et finalement les fils comme
des couleurs pour créer cette illusion
extraordinaire de de l'ombre sur le sol
comme on a pu le voir tout à l'heure
c'est à partir de ce moment là que je me
suis que j'ai commencé à me poser la
question du temps dans les objets alors
pas le temps des objets savoir si un
objet et ancien précieux mais le temps
déposé par celui qui a conçu et fabriqué
l'objet et dans quelle mesure le temps
qu'ils avaient été déposés pouvait être
perçu par celui qui regarde est utilisé
l'objet aujourd'hui
alors certains des artistes des artisans
mais aussi dans le milieu industriel
produisent des objets qu'on peut
vraiment qualifier de ce lot c'est à
dire avec un très fort investissement
temporel alors en 2012 en france
certains ont même lancé le mouvement
slow made qui vise à rassembler
tous ceux qui se retrouvent derrière
cette formule de fait avec tout le temps
nécessaire fait avec tout le temps
nécessaire ça veut dire pas forcément
particulièrement lentement mais en se
donnant tous les moyens y compris le
temps d'atteindre l'objectif qu'on
s'était fixés alors on voit que là on
touche à quelque chose qui est plus de
l'ordre du luxe aujourd'hui en tout cas
qui fait plus vraiment partie de notre
quotidien
pour moi ces objets slow sont de très
bons exemples pour essayer d'analyser en
voilà ce temps des pauses et qui serait
en quelque sorte encapsulé en eux alors
là la table et la chaise que vous avez
sous vos yeux sont pour moi des bons
exemples
ils ont été produits par le mobilier
national à paris qui au delà de meubler
les palais officiel produit également
tout un tas d'objets des tapis des
tapisseries du mobilier dans un cadre
temporel littéralement extraordinaire
puisque certains artisans certains
techniciens son et la plupart en fait
sont amenés à travailler sur un produit
plusieurs années l'unité temporelle pour
un tapis ou une tapisserie c'est plutôt
l'année que le moi en fait
est ce donc c'est vraiment des
archétypes d'objets slot et cette table
et cette chaise sont le résultat d'un
processus assez long de recherche et
développement en quelque sorte qui a
abouti au choix de la matière qui est en
fait de la fibre de carbone et pourquoi
cette matière at-elle été choisie parce
que c'était finalement celle qui
permettait est la seule quelque part qui
permettait d'atteindre le résultat que
le designer rêvait à savoir un bureau
extrêmement long mais qui devrait rester
stable et avec cette espèce de vortex au
milieu on voit c'est que ces creux et en
fait ils ont abouti à choisir la fibre
de carbone ce qui a nécessité
pour les techniciens de se former à ces
matériaux composites auquel il n'était
pas forcément formé initialement pour
aboutir au résultat que l'on voit
aujourd'hui sous les yeux alors
finalement que nous raconte que nous
que nous apprennent ces objets et que
contiennent t-il pour moi à la fois donc
ils contiennent ils contiennent tout ce
dont ils sont dépositaires un
savoir-faire une intention un projet une
persévérance et s'ils contiennent tout
ceci alors on peut aller y puiser ils
sont des réceptacles extrêmement fécond
on peut ressentir de l'admiration pour
un savoir faire
on peut s'interroger sur une contrainte
technique surmonter on peut ressentir de
la gratitude de l'admiration pour la
personne qui a réalisé l'objet qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui mais ils sont pas
seulement des conteneurs passifs ils
sont aussi des sortes de générateur pour
moi il déclenche en fait des façons de
penser et des postures et des tournures
d'esprit différentes
ils nous permettent de ressentir des
doutes des questionnements notamment par
rapport à notre rapport à la
productivité et ceux à louisa y est
c'est ce qu'ont pourquoi on veut
toujours être arrivé avant d'être parti
alors bien sûr on peut aussi recette
ressentir enfin se sentir mal à l'aise
face à des objets notamment des objets
qui sont très investis techniquement
alors typiquement la marqueterie fait
partie de ces techniques qui sont très
consommatrices de temps et pour
lesquelles on visualise bien la personne
en train de passer un temps infini à
assembler des petits morceaux et c'est
vrai que face à ce type d'objet on peut
se dire mais bon sang pourquoi at-il ou
at elle passé tant de temps sur une
seule pièce il y aquelques par une sorte
de vanité et peut-être une limite une
nausée alors là j'ai donné l'exemple du
bureau à cylindre de marie-antoinette
mais je pense qu'on pourrait ressentir
ce cet état d'esprit devant un objet qui
ne seraient même pas
réel mais peut-être virtuel mais dont on
pourrait sentir la matière par exemple
un film d'animation extrêmement léchée
une planche de bd ou un jeu vidéo ou
quelque chose comme ça et c'est vrai que
devant ce genre d'objets parfois je me
disais que quelque part il faisait trop
de bruit et il est d'autres objets qui
sont plus silencieux qui révèle - qui
est allemand leur richesse au premier
abord mais qui parle vide qu'il crée
nous offre des plages de liberté qui
sont extrêmement puissante
ce bol a été réparée selon la technique
du kin sugi c'est une technique
japonaise du 15e siècle qui pourrait se
traduire par jointures d'or dans ce cas
lorsqu'un objet est cassé on choisit non
pas de le jeter
comme dans beaucoup dans notre société
mais de le réparer sans pour autant
cacher la réparation mais au contraire
quelque part en la sublimant avec cette
technique fait fait non pas de colle
mais de lacs et de poudre d'or et dans
ce cas notamment dans le cas d'un bol
évidemment l'objet redevient fonctionnel
il repart littéralement pour une
deuxième vie ou son possesseur valorise
à la fois son histoire et son esthétique
et quelque part on pourrait se dire
finalement c'est peut-être pas le
trop-plein trop-plein de de matière de
savoir-faire d'investissement de temps
qui est la vraie richesse de ces objets
mais peut-être précisément le vide
cet espace de liberté
cet espace de projection personnelle
qui est la vraie la vraie rencontre et
justement cette rencontre peut-être que
la vraie rencontre
elle ne se fait pas dans l'objet ni même
en moi même mais dans cet écart est cet
antre au moment de la rencontre
et quelque part c'est peut-être
exactement au moment où je suis
traversée par l'expérience que cela a de
la valeur alors pour moi cette cette
expérience cet idéal a changé ma vie
parce qu'elle m'a incité à m'inscrire
dans un nouveau cursus d'études
universitaires et essayer de faire
rentrer tout ça dans ma vie ce qui est
un challenge mais elle même elle me fait
elle me prend du temps quelque part en
lecture en travaillant rencontre mais
elle m'a fait découvrir des plages de de
réflexion que je n'aurais pas imaginé
car ces objets nous raconte énormément
de choses et nous incite à raconter à
projeter finalement notre propre récit
du monde et dans notre rapport au temps
et au monde pour peut-être l'habiter un
peu plus lentement un peu plus
poétiquement est un peu moins
prosaïquement alors l'idée n'est pas de
ne s'entourer que d'objets d'artisanat
d'art comme on a pu voir de route de
rejeter tous les objets manufacturés ou
même tous les objets tout court mais
peut-être de laisser leurs chances de
faire de la place à ce type d'objet
parce que précisément ils nous
permettent de faire de la place dans
notre quotidien
donc dans notre esprit pour faire
émerger ces espaces de créativité de
rêve dont on a tant besoin et de récits
et voilà ce que je voulais vous
proposait c'était de tenter cette
expérience de donner leur chance à ces
objets que j'appelle ce lot pour ouvrir
finalement des espaces de respiration
qui sont devenus extrêmement nécessaire
nécessaires et utiles dans notre
quotidien il est dans notre dans notre
vie aujourd'hui
alors voilà c'est dans vos mains
aujourd'hui et
vous n'avez plus qu'à en faire
l'expérience merci
[Musique]